he is without a doubt my favorite Ohio
State Buckeye fan there's not a very
long list to be yeah well there's Graham
ray Hall and that's it I can't stand
anybody else I really can't good to see
my friend it in in I guess an in Honda
partnership as well as from rll racing
from IndyCar good to see you thank you
sir good to see you man
so here's how it goes Brockman over the
weekend okay I'm taking in it's the only
way to put it the Peach Bowl yes in
Atlanta not going well no no no it's not
going well I look down at my phone and I
see a text and it is from our guest
Graham ray Hall let me see if I can get
this age we put up on the screen I'm
it's gentle I'm honestly shocked I
didn't expect this at all my response
dude you're like I know big names are
missing but man I was shocked like for
once in my life I'm like you know what
just want the big 10 to win here okay
for once Amala particularly against the
sec and once again Oh
Harbaugh oh no is there any part of you
at all Graham that thought in between
your temples you're smart man you're
very smart man you come from excellent
stock no you thought I wouldn't want to
hear from you at all at that point in
time no you know I thought I was kind of
being nice but I was also still getting
in my sort of Michigan you know and this
year I didn't text you leading up to the
game I I was I was quiet I didn't make a
show appearance until now so we don't
have a bet correct and I thought that
maybe this year wasn't gonna be Ohio
State year which is why you didn't so I
was quiet no no no that's what exactly
you didn't because you thought but I
could I could have rubbed that in like
crazy yet I was I was gentle but the
I got Brockman you know me as well as
anybody else and util Delta folk the
number of times what after I wrote dude
and then you wrote back you know I know
guys are missing but man a number of
times I wrote in something so profane
that we wouldn't have been able to show
it on the screen right there and erased
it because I thought to myself you know
what he's just he's just a nice guy yeah
I thought I was being nice I mean I I
thought I was being somewhat gentle for
what the the score was right you know
and the performance was I thought I I
wasn't being overly overly harsh no but
uh so my response was are you in LA I
invited you on your show which was here
you are because I thought to myself
again you know what it's possible you
are just the nice guy that you are but
you were just you were needling me a
little bit I was trying to be I thought
I was being gentle because actually for
the first time like I said I was hoping
Michigan was gonna win because I just
wanted the big ten to look good and I
was sitting there listening to this
thing wasn't watching I was driving home
from right I'm like tal I'm listening to
them like are you what is happening
right now right and so you know when
there's a comment to be made the first
guy I thought of was you now are you are
you when your Buckeyes are struggling
against Indiana no and then are you are
you texting David Letterman the same
stuff too like hey man you guys know but
too bad no you don't do that do you no I
normally do that do it normally text all
my media buddies in Columbus Ohio like
what is happening right now
I do sometimes get like bitching
complaining text from you and I'm like
that is the role I event I just have to
have you know sometimes things come up
and I just have to I've got to say
something
the dude wins ninety percent of his
games what are you complaining no I know
which do you know Marv dude your urban
yeah you a man you were gonna miss him
looks we know I think we will what do
you mean you think you will you're not
grinding dad's gonna win ninety percent
I think Ryan dazing me very good you
think he's going to win I don't think in
his career he'll win ninety percent like
urban is urban is a special category of
competitive and winner and everybody
but like from everything I hear like
inside the purchase from buddies and
stuff like Ryan Day I think and I met
him but I met him like super briefly yes
I think he's gonna he's gonna win over
that that place pretty quickly okay so
let me look at Rich Eisen show
researcher el Zorro we had no idea I was
going to do the math for me 75 percent
winning percentage would be what is that
10 and 2 is that 10 and 2 can you look
that up because you will not be able to
handle a 10 and 2 football season no you
will be bitching and moaning one of my
one of my best buddies Cory out here
he's a die-hard USC guy right and so he
is going on about you know we go we go
to the USC Notre Dame game they lose and
not bowl bound or anything and I'm like
man we are so spoiled because like if
Ohio State loses one game a year the sky
the world the sky is falling
any Alabama fan when save and moves on
can be the exact same thing you know
they lose more than zero games a year or
one it's the world is gonna come to an
end and that's how we kind of feel over
the last seven years and even before
that with Tressel and all honestly I
mean trust like they won all the time in
the one year with with fickle who did a
great job just here at cincy you know we
lost with five games or six alone Tom
Herman's Texas win too you can own it
all go for not all I know I don't know
Dan Mullen beat Michigan he's no no no
no no no I'm not Tom Herman I'm not
gonna even do that either
cuz that opens the door do another yeah
I don't want to get into that topic so
we'll just leave
[Music]
but I was shocked last night I think we
all were okay
Graham Rahal here Rich Eisen show so
what is the what 75 not 9 and 3 yeah
you've we fought with anion three season
you went 75 percent of his games see you
not good okay 90 percent of your dog
their big key yeah and I heard you guys
talking about Notre Dame earlier yes you
got to win the big ones and typically
urban is good at winning the big ones
he's winning at law and that's where
it's even better like this year after we
lost to Purdue's like okay we're done
but if we can be Michigan who cares and
so after that day my life was was great
and I didn't blow you up
I was super quiet and whatever else I
heard from anybody but I owned it I mean
I there was I was retort --less I had no
retort there was a shocking shock I
don't need to hear that shocking game
but anyway anyway well so do you think
he's done cuz when he was asked do we
have that soundbite do we have the
soundbite from from Tom Rinaldi let's
play this for a high OH State Buckeye
fan a big rll racer Graham Rahal let's
check it I'm done tap dancing with the
set up here it is well the moment has
come
what do you reflect upon I reflect on
I'm a very blessed person with my family
every blessed I've had some of the best
coaches in college football coach for me
and you look at our rosters over the
years you could say as we've had the
best players ever played this game and
I'm very proud of that
is a very big word what are the chances
we'll never see you lead another team
out of a tunnel I don't believe us gonna
happen
I'm gonna enjoy tonight I don't believe
I want to coach together I mean I don't
I don't know that I
I believe that Ohio State I think was
his dream job
when I met him and I spent some time
with him at his office he he was showing
me pictures of him as a kid you know in
Ohio State I mean I believe that part of
it but I think that the passion like
Mack Brown you know I think when it's in
you it's kind of hard to let that go I
do think the health stuff of course all
my Michigan but you don't have any
health problems come Sheree I think that
he does and I think that's probably I
think from a family perspective that's
probably the biggest thing that's kind
of stopped him here now right but never
is a big word like when I when my dad
retired you know he had raised his
entire life dad do you never want to
drive a car again
yep I'm done I'm done four years later
you know he's racing vintage cars I mean
never is a that's a loaded question but
I don't know you know we'll see I mean
maybe maybe it is he's got to have
enough money right I mean and he's won
pretty much the only thing I think that
could probably like burn away at a guy
like that which would be the same that
would be like in our in our world you
know the REA halls and the Andretti's
growing up there's ray halls and Reddy's
you know you just don't get all and if
you know to just put it bluntly if Marco
Andretti goes out there and wins an Indy
500 and I retire it someday and I don't
win one it's gonna burn at me every day
and maybe you know for urban that's Nick
Saban I don't know but that's the only
way I could see anything changeable I
don't know I've never I mean I met him
but I've never really I don't talk to
him yeah and so I don't know what is his
real sense of it is but I would be
really shocked if that's it forever I I
firmly believe he's got health problems
you know what I mean like I thought that
the fact that he couldn't remember some
important things about the Zack Smith
situation because of his medical okay a
little bit dicey
okay and
and a very Pat explanation on behalf of
Mary Jo white as to what certain things
were but him bending over his waist at
crucial moments at them in the Maryland
game when he collapsed that's that that
is he's not he's not not joining a haha
just to put on airs about something I
think he's also pissed at what happened
at Ohio State in August and I am too and
I think he made a decision that based on
all together I am done here and I'm
gonna win these last couple games and
I'm finished here I thought at that time
that that not because of him getting
fired I never saw him getting fired in
that scenario but I still thought that
the stress of that time was gonna
probably be it he came back obviously
they did a good job this year and then
as we just talked about I just feel like
Ryan Day already had kind of won over
the locker room and everything else he
did a great job at the start of the year
he schemed a hell of a game against
Michigan oh I just think like that it
was just the perfect scenario you know
for him to kind of step in but you look
at like trestle I mean trestle could go
coach at other places now he's what the
president of Youngstown State or someone
taking it as a different size than Ohio
State but I mean maybe you know maybe
there are other roles for for urban to
to fit but I use Mack Brown you know
kind of as the standard because a guy
that I like respect tremendously I'm
sure you know him personally but you
know to go back and coach at his age now
Oh everything every coach got to be in
here you know the fire is always for
generally guys competitive is Ervin the
fires here all the time it's got to be
hard to let that go so are you gonna are
you gonna become a UFC Fan next year no
you'd be pissed wouldn't you he shows up
at USC next year you're pissed a little
bit right he that's not gonna happen
what's today's date 1 to 19 let's check
in on 1 to 20 see where it was you
really think that's if if clay Helton
does not work out here and you actually
throw a load huh
throw them every penny they can possibly
find oh yeah and it's gonna happen every
year every year that to Chip Kelly and
how'd that work out this year I know it
does take time but still that urban at
USC would be it's the right market you
know that's wrong a guy a lot Notre Dame
that's another dream Java is too right I
don't see that happening I thought I
don't know like you talked about
everything else like which is which is
obviously very valid I feel like a Notre
Dame yeah man Notre Dame being what it
is that should be but Brian Kelly I
thought pushed the limits of Notre Dame
from kind of just the rumblings of his
past but it's his job as long as he
wants it I don't think you could say
that about clay Helton right now I was
surprised it was his job next year this
is all I've got
this is all I'm hanging my hat on right
now it's all good I really don't know
man I I have no clue but all I know is
they they got it done yesterday it was
good yeah couple questions for you
before I let you go you get back in the
car one when are you back in the car
I'll get back in about a week so we'll
start firing up start testing the Indy
car this year's really the same platform
as last we've got some changes at our
team last year we we didn't get a win
which was disappointing and years before
that we had we've gotten five and only a
couple years so getting the race engine
turn that around the Honda the platform
is the same but obviously and actually
our engines are built right up the road
here Santa Clarita okay and so that will
be I'm sure they've updated them quite a
bit but we'll find out January 15th
first time I get back in okay and then
your first race is when one date Pete
st. Pete Grand Prix that's beginning of
March again in March and then we got a
couple new venues this here we go to
Austin Texas circa the Americas which is
cool we go back to Laguna Seca which is
in Monterey California awesome the back
straights named after my dad and that
creamer race there and I don't know 15
years so a lot of a lot of good stuff
coming and then soldiers strong is the
program but with ray whole Letterman
Lanigan racing and the United Rentals
incorporated which is what you write
across route and blazing right across
your chest right now what is soldiers
strong so soldiers strong is our is a
group that we work with our initiative
is called turns for troops every lap I
complete throughout the IndyCar schedule
United Rentals donates $50 a lap we also
host the Graham Rahal Foundation charity
golf tournament in May it's the Thursday
before the Indy 500 and our goal with
soldier strong is to use higher
technologies things like exoskeleton
suits that allows paralyzed veterans to
walk again actually one of our drivers
that runs with us Robert Wiccans got in
a really bad crash last year at Pocono
and had a spinal injury and he's using
an exoskeleton currently to to get back
up on his feet and but it's technologies
that they're using now it's developing
into many other things but our goal
every year is to at least buy one
exoskeleton to the cost of about a
hundred and fifty thousand this year
thanks to United Rentals and all of our
partners at our charity golf tournament
we raised over $300,000 so we got to to
exoskeletons but it's something kind of
fun if you go to turns for troops comm
you can follow it as it kind of ticks
over throughout the year the amount of
laps that we do we update it people can
buy shirts it's similar like this but
all the money goes to goes to the
foundation that goes to turn for troops
so it's really cool I mean obviously
anything that we can do you guys do it a
lot too anything we can do to give back
is you know we're all blessed to be in
the position that we're in and we owe it
you know to get back particularly you
know to veterans to me it's something
special United Rentals huge huge huge
company we see them everywhere their
equipment is all over the place but
they're the most charitable group I have
ever been around by far and so really it
was their brainchild and you know we're
excited to carry this thing on that's
awesome over a half million dollars in
race to date since you started in 2016
last one for you what goes first your
mustache or Letterman's beard huh
pry the stache
a Letterman Letterman agreed if we win
the Indy 500 when we win the Indy 500
like it that the beard is a goner but
the moustache look this is a month in
the making okay it's not pretty I get it
yeah I'm not try it's not trying to be
pretty but my dad was known for this
legendary thick stache yes you didn't
pass that down to you know the the
facial hair thing was not passed down so
I my wife Courtney she's very against
this she told me on New Year's she's
like if you have that I'm not kidding I
will find somebody else to kiss but I
was the only guy in the room so I was I
was safe by 50 numbers I am I am going
to this might last dad is dad's not a
fan the other day and he's like Graham
no you got it that's got to go
but we're gonna give it a shot in our
media day as at the beginning of
February if it's not pretty by February
it will have to I don't know I mean it's
right now it's like I said it's not good
it's a very Boogie Nights issue not
working here right this is the best I've
ever been able to achieve I turned 30 in
two days and this is this is all I have
I've accepting it and Wow you know so we
we at least have the Letterman beard
until memorial day's work yeah yeah we
got a little while okay that's I don't
think that is gonna change though okay
so you can only can control what you can
control and even if your wife and dad
say get rid of it you be you that's I
took it I took a social media poll today
on my Instagram and stuff about it right
and most of the votes are keep it keep
going wrong people I get people have
spoken
we're gonna try grandma all out Graham
ray on Twitter and also Instagram good
to see a man thank you thank you guys
and I'm so glad you reached out to me
with a very unkind cut but you were very
gentle about it and it's led to you
being here on the program so it's good
to see you well thank you Graham Rahal
right here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience